الى اخر تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
حيث وافاد مراسل الجزيره بوقوع السلسله
انفجارات قويه في العاصمه الاوكرانيه
مع رصد اجسام طائره في سماء المدينه وقد
تصدت الدفاعات الجويه لها ووقت كاميرا
الجزيره صور الارسام الطائره والانفجارات
التي وقعت في اجواء المدينه من جهتها
الاداره العسكريه سقوط حطام عدد من
الصواريخ في اربعه احياء مختلفه من
العاصمه
وطالبت السكان باتخاذ اجراءات السلامه
والبقاء في الملاجئ من جانبه قال عمده
تركيا من الدفاعات الجويه تتعامل مع
مسيرات انتحاريه جنوب شرق العاصمه مشيرا
الى اصابه ثلاثه اشخاص على الاقل جراء
سقوط حطام الصواريخ فضلا عن احتراق عدد من
السيارات
[موسيقى]
نتابع التفاصيل اولا باول وينضم الي من
وراسلنا حسان مسعود مرحبا حسان كنت معي في
النشره السابقه كنا نتحدث عن اجسام
الطائره بحسب وصف الجهات المعنيه في كيف
الان تبين انها مسيرات انتحاريه التفاصيل
محمد بينما نتحدث الان وفق الاداره
العسكريه
لمنطقه كييف وعمده كييف تتعامل الدفاعات
الجويه مع مسيرات انتحاريه في المنطقه
الواقعه جنوب شرق العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف
هذه الهجمه التي تتعامل معها الدفاعات
الجويه وفق المعطيات الرسميه هي الهجمه
الثانيه على العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف خلال
هذه الليله التي يمكن وصفها بالليله غير
المسبوقه التي شهدتها العاصمه الاوكرانيه
سلسله من الانفجارات القويه للغايه في
سماء العاصمه الاوكرانيه وهذه الانفجارات
ناجمه عن سماع ذوي انفجار
للدفاعات الجويه في السماء من جهه
لسماع ذوي انفجارات ناجمه ايضا عن
الصواريخ
سيارات التي اطلقت نحو العاصمه الاوكرانيه
حتى هذه اللحظه لم يتم الاعلان بشكل دقيق
عن عدد هذه الصواريخ التي اطلقت نحو
العاصمه عن نوع الصواريخ التي ايضا
استهدفت العاصمه وعن ايضا عدد المسيرات
التي اطلقت باتجاه مدينه كييف ولكننا
نستطيع ان نؤكد ان عددا كبيرا من الدفاعات
الجويه من صواريخ الدفاعات الجويه على
مختلف انواعها المنتشره في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه والتي تحاول ان تحمي هذه
العاصمه وان تسقط اكبر عدد ممكن من
الاهداف الجويه التي توجه نحو انطلقت خلال
هذه الليله وهو ما زاد من حجم سماع يدوي
انفجارات في سماء العاصمه بشكل نستطيع ان
نؤكد انه غير مسبوق منذ بدايه الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا بهذه الكثافه وبهذا
الشكل وبهذه الاصوات المرتفعه للغايه بل
وحتى في الاماكن التي قامت الدفاعات
الجويه باعتراض صواريخ فيها حتى هذه
اللحظه ووفق المعطيات الاوليه كما يؤكد
عمله كييف هناك اربع اماكن على الاقل رصد
فيها حطام للصواريخ التي
سقطت في
المناطق المختلفه في العاصمه الاوكرانيه
اربع احياء مختلفه اكثر الاحياء التي
تاثرت بهذه الضربه على ما يبدو وفق
المعطيات الرسميه ايضا هو
حيسكي وهذا الحي قالت الاداره العسكريه ان
هناك مبنى مساحته 200 متر تعرض للضرر
وتشتعل فيه النيران وتحديدا ايضا هناك
اعلن عن اصابه ثلاثه اشخاص على الاقل نحن
ما زلنا تحت تاثير حظر التجول في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه بقي عليه نصف ساعه حتى الان
وربما بسبب هذا الحظر حظر التجول لم نشهد
اعدادا مرتفعه او كبيره من الاصابات وربما
الضحايا بفعل هذه الهجمه الصاروخيه
والهجمه
ولكن بكل الاحوال يجري الحديث عن انواع من
الصواريخ ويجري تداول عدد من صور حطام هذه
الصواريخ التي على ما يبدو انها صواريخ
كبيره
اطلقت باتجاه العاصمه الاوكرانيه وربما
هذا سبب سماع الانفجارات بقوه كبيره في
سماء العاصمه الاوكرانيه
وايضا
مراقبه ورصد الدوري الكبير والشعاع الكبير
الذي صدر عن هذه الانفجارات التي وقعت في
العاصمه لفتره طويله محمد اكثر من عشر
دقائق استمرت اصوات الانفجارات واصوات
الصواريخ في سماء الع الاوكرانيه كييف
وكنا نشاهد بشكل واضح هذه الدفاعات الجويه
كما الصواريخ تحلق في سماء العاصمه ويبدو
واضحا انها كانت ايضا في المنطقه الواقعه
وسط العاصمه هنا حيث نوجد الان في وسط
العاصمه الاوكرانيه بالقرب من ميدان
الاستقلال وبالقرب من عدد من المراكز
الحكوميه مبنى الحكومه المحليه
في وسط كياب مبنى محافظه ومقاطعه كييف
وكذلك مبنى البلديه وبالقرب من هذه
المنطقه ايضا يقع قصر الرئيس الاوكراني
فلنسي الذي عاد خلال هذه الليله فقط الى
اوكرانيا بعد زياره الى اوروبا خلال هذه
الزياره كان من بين اهم المواضيع التي
نقشها وفق ايضا تصريحاته الرسميه هو جلب
المزيد من المساعدات
العسكريه وتحديدا المساعدات المرتبطه
بالدفاعات الجويه التي قال ان هذه
الدفاعات تحمي سماء اوكرانيا وتحديدا
العاصمه الاوكرانيه وتحمي حياه السكان وفق
تعبيره وهو ما يشير الى اهميه هذه
الدفاعات الجويه التي كانت تعمل طيله هذه
الليله ولكن بكل الاحوال لا نستطيع ان
نؤكد مدى دقه الاصابات التي قامت بها
الدفاعات الجويه حتى هذه اللحظه نظرا لان
المعطيات الرسميه لم تنشر حتى اللحظه ولكن
راينا وشاهدنا عدد من الصور التي نشرت
للكاميرات كاميرات المراقبه في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه والتي اظهرت ان انفجارات وقعت
في العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف وفي عدد من
المناطق خلال هذه الليله
الروايه الرسميه حتى اللحظه لا تتحدث الا
عن سقوط حطام هذه الصواريخ في المناطق مخت
في العاصمه لكن ما رايناه كان انفجارات
قويه وكبيره في عدد من مناطق العاصمه محمد
حسن مسعود مراسله الجزيره كنت معي من كيف
شكرا على كل هذه التوضيحاته والتفاصيل